[Music]
this will be our last question from
roshewski again which is will the church
be purified
yes
i'm hesitating a yes an impure church
cannot be taken to heaven it has to be
purified i mean of all impurities before
christ comes back um christ object
lesson space 69 paragraph one when the
character of christ shall be perfectly
reproducing his people then he will come
to claim them as his own yes the church
must be purified from all impurities
and that's the church that will be alive
in the last days when christ comes back
now those who died died moving towards
that goal of purification they are
covered by the righteous members of
christ element rise in faith and work
space 50 paragraph one when it is in the
heart to obey god and efforts are made
towards that end but accepts this as our
best effort makes up for the deficiency
with his own divine marriage the thief
on the cross didn't have a chance to
live a righteous holy life but he was
covered by the righteousness pride enoch
had a chance to do that either way both
will enter the kingdom of god sinless
the church must be purified
but not against its will we must
cooperate with the purifier which is
christ both he that sanctifieth and
those who are sanctified are all of one
how can you be one with christ and
you're a right sinner i am not allowed
to be one with christ is to be like him
he's not so much he like us even though
he did human form but ultimately
spiritually it is to be like him
he took our condition that we might be
like him he lives a sinless life in our
weak nature that we might be like him
that's why he did not have any
tendencies he never practiced it
so yes the church has to be purified
it is god's will
first thessalonians 4 3 this is the will
of god even your sanctification is the
process of purification
but let me say this when you think of
the church think of you
not just the build think of you you are
a part of the church you must be
purified i must be purified this is not
a group thing so much it is a collection
of individuals you purify and god brings
them together
god did make adam and eve together he
made them separately i say that all the
time
mind capital personality volume 2 page 4
23 paragraph 2 the gospel deals with
individuals make sure that god is
purifying you
the church is fine but you are the
church let god purify you i hate to be
so emphatic but i had to
amen
that's right i think that's the end but
you know as you were speaking i was
thinking about what we were also talking
about before that in order to preach the
gospel we need to be purified
perpetually
you know it has you know we have to
allow the word of god really to be
metabolized in us so that we can be
ready for when he comes and be able to
even speak
for the truth because at the end of the
day
we cannot bring out what has not been
put in and internalized
so it's it's a word that's a big word dr
mccrichen it must be metabolized tell us
what that means
it needs to be broken down into its
smallest units and get themselves
exactly and i know you preach a message
on that all right if it's in the cell
you can't vomit it up it's there it
stays if it's in the stomach you can
bring it back up in the cell you cannot
bring it back up christ must reach the
cellular level spiritually you can't
regurgitate christ when he's in the
cells his righteousness
most of us have him in the stomach so we
vomit him when he doesn't give us what
we want he must be in the cells
nutrition that hasn't reached the cell
does you know good
it just comes out
anyway that was an aside
anything else
you